nommé brigitte nous ne serons pas
davantage engagés même pas par cette
réforme par ses oukases organisé par des
préfets aux ordres dans l'affolement et
la crainte des dernières élections
régionales pour le pouvoir en place
donc pas plus que les grandes régions
pas plus que le découpage départemental
nous ne serons engagés par cela premier
point deuxième point paulin et je vous
soumettrai demain une proposition
c'est un débat très important entre nous
est-ce que la france un message
universel n'est pas un petit sujet
certains disent gardons nos soldats pour
simplement nous protéger ne nous mêlons
plus de ce qui se passe ailleurs
moi j'ai une autre idée de ce qu'est la
france
la france est membre permanent du
conseil de sécurité la france un message
universel
la france est sans doute avec les états
unis l'un des rares pays qui pensent que
ses idées ne va pas simplement pour son
territoire mais aussi pour une large
partie du monde l'influencent de la
france va bien au delà des 66 millions
de français ce qui nous impose un effort
financier au service de notre appareil
militaire sans commune mesure et un
réseau diplomatique d'une importance
exceptionnelle
moi je souhaite qu'on continue à jouer
ce rôle
on en débattra mais il ya un point que
je veux souligner il ya une différence
entre ce qui se passe en méditerranée et
ce qui a pu se passer pour l'afghanistan
où pour l'irak
l'union pour la méditerranée que j'ai
tellement voulu
elle doit être la clé de notre politique
étrangère
mais ce que vous oubliez tunis et à 780
kilomètres de nice si demain l'algérie
le maroc la tunisie s'effondre alors ce
sera même pas la peine de parler de
politique d'immigration
est ce que vous croyez que la sécurité
dans votre métro dans votre un dépendra
simplement du nombre de policiers que
vous y mettrez ou de la politique
étrangère que vous serez capable de
mettre en oeuvre pour pacifier la
méditerranée chaque fois que nous avons
tourné le dos à la méditerranée
nous avons cru tourner le dos à notre
passé en vérité nous avons tourné le dos
à notre avenir
voilà la vérité la france est une
puissance méditerranéenne la paix et la
civilisation dépendra de la paix et de
la civilisation au nord et au sud la
politique méditerranéenne ce n'est pas
une politique étrangère
c'est notre culture c'est notre
civilisation et c'est notre avenir
ce sera l'un des thèmes que je vous
proposerai demain je vous ai promis des
débats de fond
ça sera pas simplement des débats sur
l'actualité
faut-il une politique méditerranéenne
faut-il un appareil de défense faut-il
un réseau diplomatique
faut-il que des jeunes français payent
le prix du sang pour l'idéal de la
république française le mes chers amis
nous sommes les républicains si nous
n'avons pas d'ambition pour la france et
les valeurs universelles qu'elle porte
c'est pas la peine de se consacrer à la
vie politique
voilà en tout cas ce qu est la
conviction qui est la mienne